zero 8 1 1 2 7 8 8 2 is a hard number to
remember if you chunk the number into 0
8 1 1 2 7 8 8 2 it's easier cutting
large bits of information into smaller
pieces helps us to understand if we put
small pieces back together we can see
the big picture and that helps us to
remember the process is called chunking
this is how it works our short-term
memory is fast but tiny according to
learning expert dr. Oakley it can hold
on the 4 chunks of information at once
so when new inputs arrive it has 2 ways
to pick them up first it can overwrite
and forget what it has to make space for
new information or it can use mental
effort to move a chunk from the working
memory into the long-term memory where
it can be stored and remembered later
this is why it's almost impossible to
recall 9 digits like 0 8 1 1 2 7 8 8 2
there is simply not enough space once
chunked
there is there are several ways to chunk
you can break a larger piece into
smaller bits identify patterns or group
pieces to see the larger picture once
the chunk is created you can use
deliberate practice to move it into your
long-term memory where it connects with
existing experiences now it can be
stored for years and if regularly used
accessed without much mental effort to
make this transfer more effective it
helps to add context which acts like
memory super glue great instructors
always try to give you the big picture
before going into detail if you study by
yourself you can skim through your
textbook first by reading chapter
headlines learning facts without
understanding the big picture is pretty
useless as we will forget what we have
learned very fast
professional piano teachers first show
their students the entire song so they
understand the mood then they ask their
students to practice one measure at a
time once the part has been learned and
the neural connections in the brain have
been built then students go on to the
next measure after all chunks can be
played separately they are combined
until the entire piece is connected now
the student can played a piece with less
mental effort chunking also helps to
understand complex topics say trade
between China and India first study
China the people the culture and the
economy then summarize and put what you
learned in your own simple language
repeat the process for India then study
trade itself the mechanics benefits and
problems again simplify to form an
underlying idea at the end you might
just have summarised several books onto
one napkin try hunting next time you
feel the limits of your working memory
just like how clever restaurants chunk
their menus into starters Mane's and
desserts with three to four options each
with chunking it's easy to compare our
options and make a decision if you like
our videos and want to support our
channel visit us at patreon.com slash
sprouts and see if you want to donate
just $1 with your support we plan to
create many more minute videos about
learning and education
[Music]